they are the captors who are now the
captives newly released pictures of the
two British Isis militants now being
held by Syrian Kurdish forces and this
was just one of their victims the
American journalist Jim Foley tortured
and beheaded an execution filmed by his
kidnappers Jim's childhood friend took
that his mother now campaigns for the
protection of journalists she gave me
her reaction to the capture of the
British jihadis I was relieved mark
because I was starting to wonder if if
anyone could be held accountable anybody
but we're very hopeful that they will
soon be elsewhere and brought to trial
that's my hope and you say brought to
trial where would you like them to be
brought to trial and what sort of trial
would you prefer well I would prefer a
friend a federal criminal court be that
in the UK or the US or The Hague just
some country that would be capable to do
a public fair trial you know oh
absolutely mark absolutely there is a
thought that these men may go straight
to Guantanamo Bay what what would
jewelry I should be if I would be very
against that I'll be very against that
it would continue the hatred part of you
know they were executed in orange
jumpsuits like used in Guantanamo so I
would be very against that I think that
would be a travesty I think that would
perpetuate this cycle of hatred that I
think we need to be above that and I
think we need to show them what justice
really looks like and try you think one
of us should be shut down right now
that's my opinion yes of course
I just so if you could speak to these
men now what would you say to them I
feel very sorry for them I mean had they
known Jim they would have loved Jim and
what do you think Jim would say to them
if he could talk to them now and he
would have wanted to know why why where
are you coming from I mean
these young men were brought up in Great
Britain and you know why and what
radicalized them he would want to
understand I'm sure what would bring
them to that to such barbaric twisted
view of the world you know and if there
is justice now for these two men anyway
would that in any way add up to some
sort of closure for you in this the real
closure obviously would be if Jim were
to come back but but sure I mean all you
can hope for in this world is that some
justice is served
and that other people are protected from
the kind of evil that was inflicted on
our son and the others out that would
give us a lot of solace mark one mother
praying today that justice delayed will
not be justice denied
Marc Austin sky news in New Hampshire